.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WE'RE COMING UP ON THE TWO-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT.
SEEMS LIKE A DAY.
PETE BUTTIGIEG HAS BEEN THERE
ALMOST THE WHOLE TIME.
HE WAS SWORN IN IN EARLY
FEBRUARY OF 2021.
WHEN HE WAS, HE HAD HIGH HOPES.
HE HAD NO PREVIOUS EXPERIENCE
WITH TRANSPORTATION OR
SECRETARIAL WORK.
BUTTIGIEG SWORE AND OATH TO BE
THE BEST DARN SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION HE COULD BE.
HE SEEMED TO MEAN IT BUT NOT FOR
LONG.
SADLY HISTORY INTERVENED, A WEEK
IN THE JOB, SOME OF THE ROADS
HE'S SUPPOSED TO BE OVERSEAING,
THE ROADS HE'S SECRETARY OF,
WERE RACIST.
NOT JUST LOW-GRADE RACIST, NO
THAT KIND OF RACISM, THESE WERE
HARDCORE DAVID DUKE LEVEL NASTY
OLD SEGREGATIONIST ROADS.
ROADS THAT REFUSED TO RESPOND TO
REASON AND HAD NO INTENTION OF
CHANGING.
SOME OF THESE ROADS HAD WHITE
STRIPES PAINTED ON THEM.
WHITE STRIPES.
JIM CROW STUFF.
BUTTIGIEG SEEMED SHOCKED BY THE
WHOLE THING.
THEY DON'T HAVE ROADS LIKE THAT
IN SOUTH BEND, INDIANA.
SO FOR PETE, IT WAS A PIVOT
POINT.
EVERYTHING CHANGES IN AN
INSTANT.
ALL YOUR PRECONCEPTIONS WASHED
AWAY.
HE HAD SWORN AN OATH TO TAKE
CARE OF THE ROADS BUT LEARNED
THE HARD WAY SOME ROADS ARE TOO
RACIST TO FIX.
SO PETE BUTTIGIEG EMBARKED ON
ANOTHER PATH.
HE BECAME ONE OF THE MOST
FOREMOST RELIGIOUS LEADERS.
IT WAS NOT AN EASY TRANSITION.
BUTTIGIEG HAD A
CHARACTERISTICALLY CLEVER
SOLUTION, AN APPROACH HE LEARNED
AS A McKENZIE CONSULTANT.
IN PLACE OF A GOD THAT BRINGS
JUSTICE TO THE WORLD, HE SUBJECT
TONIGHTED THE WORLD CLIMATE.
THANKS BE TO CLIMATE.
IT SOUNDED GOOD.
HERE'S ONE OF HIS SERMONS.
>> YOU TALKED OPENLY ABOUT BEING
A PERSON OF FAITH.
I WANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
CONNECT THAT TO THIS ISSUE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND OUR
CUSTODIANSHIP OF THE EARTH.
>> CLIMATE IS A MORAL ISSUE,
THIS IS ABOUT STEWARDSHIP.
IT IS ABOUT JUSTICE.
THERE'S A MOMENT HERE WHERE WE
SHOULD INVITE THOSE THAT ARE
MOTIVATED BY RELIGIOUS MORAL
CONSIDERATIONS TO KNOW THAT
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE AT STAKE IN WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO THIS PLANET.
>> Tucker: SO THIS WAS A
MILESTONE IN MODERN CHRISTIAN
THEOLOGY.
CLIMATE DECLARED FATHER
BUTTIGIEG IS A MORAL ISSUE.
NOT A METEOROLOGICAL MATTER.
IT'S A MORAL ISSUE.
CLIMATE IS A QUESTION THAT BEARS
DIRECTLY ON THE FATE OF YOUR
MORTAL SOUL.
YOU HAVE DONE TO IT THE CLIMATE.
BIG CHANGE.
YOU THOUGHT IT WAS ABOUT THE
SCIENCE.
IT'S ABOUT MORALITY.
OKAY, REVEREND PETE.
YOU SET THE TERMS HERE.
SO HOW IS YOUR CLIMATE RECORD?
SEEMS LIKE A FAIR QUESTION GIVEN
THAT YOU JUST TOLD US THAT WE
WILL GO TO HELL FOR OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS.
LET'S SEE HOW YOU'RE DOING.
FOX NEWS DIGITAL JUST GOT AHELD
OF THE REVERENT PETE'S TRAVEL
SCHEDULE.
TURNS OUT THAT REVEREND PETE IS
THE JIMMY SWAGGERT OF CLIMATE
CLERGY.
HE HAS BEEN DOING IT.
HE'S SINNED IN A DARK AND
NAUGHTY WAY.
IN LESS THAN TWO YEARS,
BUTTIGIEG HAS FLOWN PRIVATE AT
TAXPAYER EXPENSE NEARLY 20
TIMES.
JETTED TO OHIO AND FLORIDA AND
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
HE TOOK AN FAA JET TO A CANADIAN
GAY RIGHTS CEREMONY TO ACCEPT AN
AWARD FOR HIS LGBT + ADVOCACY.
THIS HAS BEEN EXPENSIVE FOR YOU
AND EVERY TAXPAYER.
DONALD TRUMP'S HHS SECRETARY TOM
PRICE LOST HIS JOB FOR DOING THE
SAME THING.
AND OUTRAGED POLITCO.COM DROVE
HIM OUT OF OFFICE.
THAT'S NOT THE REAL CLIMB.
THE REAL CLIMB HE'S AGAINST THE
CLIMATE.
IT'S A SIN.
NONE OF THESE PLANES THAT PETE
BUTTIGIEG WERE SOLAR POWERED.
NOT A SINGLE ONE RAN ON A WIND
MILL.
THEY WERE ALL FOSSIL FUELED.
PRIVATE JET TRAVEL STANDS ALONE.
PRIVATE JETS EMIT TWO TONS OF
CARBON DIOXIDE PER HOURS.
SO YOU MIGHT AS WELL START A
TIRE FIRE TO HEAT YOUR HOUSE.
THAT WOULD BE BETTER ON THE THE
ATMOSPHERE THAN WHAT PETE
BUTTIGIEG IS DOING.
TRAVELING BY PRIVATE JET IS THE
LAST THING THAT FATHER PETE
SHOULD EVER DO.
BUT WE SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED
THAT HE'S DOING IT.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT LAST YEAR
WHEN PETE BUTTIGIEG WAS BUSTED
COMMUTING IN A S.U.V., ONE OF
THE VEHICLES THAT DESTROYS THE
CLIMATE AND THEN UNLOADING A
BICYCLE FROM THE BACK SEAT FOR A
SHORT WILDLY PHOTOGRAPHED WIDE
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE FIRST
TIP THAT REVEREND PETE THAT
APPLAUDED HIS SERMONS ARE ALL
FRAUDULENT.
THEY'RE ALL FRAUDULENT.
ROUGHLY HALF OF ALL EMISSIONS
ARE EMITTED BY THE RICHEST 1% OF
THE POPULATION FLYING PRIVATE.
THE RIGHT MAJORITY OF THESE,
BIDEN VOTERS AND BIG FANS OF THE
REVEREND PETE BUTTIGIEG.
THIS YEAR ALONG, STEPHEN
SPIELBERG WHO SAID HE'S
TERRIFIED OF CLIMATE CHANGE
EMITTED OVER 4,400 METRIC TONS
OF CARBONS FROM PRIVATE JETS.
ITS SIX TIMES MORE EMISSIONS
THAN AN AVERAGE PERSON.
AND ANOTHER STAR, 8,000 TONS
EMITTED BY TAYLOR SWIFT.
ALL OF THIS ON AN OFFENSE
AGAINST MOTHER EARTH.
AND TAYLOR SWIFT SAID IT'S OKAY
BECAUSE SHE LOANS OUT HER JET, A
50-MINUTE FLIGHT ON A PRIVATE
JET CAN EMIT AS MUCH CARBON AS
AN AVERAGE PERSON'S CAR DONE
OVER AN ENTIRE YEAR.
50 MINUTES.
IMAGINE WHAT A FLIGHT FROM D.C.
TO LAX DOES OR FROM HAMPTONS TO
ASPEN.
AND THEN IMAGINE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
THESE FLIGHTS ALL CARRYING
PEOPLE THAT CLAIM THEY BELIEVE
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
IF YOU ARE YAPPING ABOUT CARBON
EMISSIONS AND FLYING CLIMATE,
YOU'RE HOISTING A SCREAMING
MIDDLE FINGER TO THE COUNTRY TO
THE PEOPLE BELOW IN THEIR
S.U.V.s THAT YOU PLAN TO BAN.
NOT JUST IN THIS COUNTRY, WE
HAVE IT EASY.
THE ECONOMIES OF ENTIRE NATIONS
AROUND THE WORLD ARE BEING
DESTROYED RIGHT NOW IN THE NAME
OF FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE AT
THE BEHEST OF THE PEOPLE THAT
FLY PRIVATE.
SO PEOPLE ARE GOING HUNGRY SO
REVEREND PETE DOESN'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE METAL DETECTOR.
IS THERE A SINGLE HIGH LEVEL
ACTOR THAT DOESN'T FLY PRIVATE?
MORE THAN 400 ATTENDEES FLEW IN
THEIR OWN PLANE.
JEFF BEZOS FLOW IN HIS PRIVATE
JET.
JOHN KERRY WAS BUSTED FLYING TO
A CLIMATE SUMMIT IN ICELAND ON
HIS PERSONAL GULFSTREAM.
DON'T WORRY.
HE'S TOO IMPORTANT.
>> IT'S THE ONLY CHOICE FOR
SOMEBODY LIKE ME THAT IS
TRAVELING THE WORLD TO WIN THIS
BATTLE.
I BELIEVE THAT THE TIME IT TAKES
ME TO GET SOMEWHERE, I CAN'T
SAIL ACROSS THE OCEAN.
I HAVE TO FLY TO MEET WITH
PEOPLE AND GET THINGS DONE.
>> Tucker: SOMEONE LIKE ME.
YOU NEVER HEARD OF ZOOM, PAL?
YOU SHOULD BE IN JAIL BY YOUR
OWN STANDARDS.
YOU'RE A CLIMATE CRIMINAL.
YOU SHOULD BE IN PRISON BY YOUR
OWN STANDARDS.
NOT JUST HIM.
VIRTUALLY EVERY RECOGNIZABLE
PERSON IN AMERICAN POLITICS
FLIES PRIVATE.
NANCY PELOSI FLIES PRIVATE.
AL GORE FLIES PRIVATE.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG FLIES PRIVATE.
THE U.S. ENVOY TOOK MORE THAN
1,600 FLIGHTS BURNING MORE THAN
10,000 METRIC TONS OF CO2.
YOU COULD NEVER DO THAT.
IF YOU FILLED YOUR YARD WITH
DIESEL ENGINES AND NEVER TURNED
THEM OFFER, YOU WOULD NEVER DO
THAT.
YOUR CAR EMITS LESS THAN FIVE
TONS OF CO2 A YEAR.
SO THIS IS MEANINGFUL.
THIS IS AN ACTUAL OFFENSE
AGAINST MOTHER EARTH AND THE
CLIMATE.
SO YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHAT THE
DEFENDERS OF CLIMATE THINK.
WHAT ABOUT GREENPEACE AND THE
SIERRA CLUB AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CLUB?
HAVE THEY NOTICED THIS?
NOT REALLY.
HAVE THEY SCOLDED THEIR DONORS
FOR UNDERMINING THEIR CORE
MESSAGE?
NO, OF COURSE NOT.
KATHERINE CLARK, THE DEMOCRATIC
HOUSE PARTY WHIP DOESN'T
COMPLAIN EITHER.
SHE SHOULD BE BECAUSE HER OWN
CHILD HAS NIGHTMARES ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHAT IT MEANS
TO ME COMING IN AS A DIFFERENT
GENERATION.
I REMEMBER MY MIDDLE CHILD
WAKING UP WITH NIGHTMARES OVER
CONCERN ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO YOU TERRORIZED YOUR OWN
CHILDREN.
YOU SCARED THE CRAP ABOUT KIDS
ABOUT CLIMATE.
SO YOU MUST BE VERY UPSET ABOUT
WHAT PETE BUTTIGIEG IS DOING TO
CLIMATE BY FLYING PRIVATE.
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE THING YOU
CAN DO TO CLIMATE OTHER THAN
SIGNING OFF ON THE SABOTAGE OF A
RUSSIAN NATURAL GAS PIPELINE.
WHICH THEY ALSO DID.
WHO IS NOTICING?
SHE'S NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT.
MEANWHILE, A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE UPSET ABOUT CLIMATE.
THEY BELIEVE PETE BUTTIGIEG.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING?
DESTROYING THE GREATEST ARTWORK
IN CIVILIZATION BECAUSE THEY
WANT YOU TO KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
THE CLIMATE IS.
>> IT SHOWS THE DESTRUCTIVE
NATURE OF OUR ADDICTION TO OIL.
>> WHAT IS WORTH MORE?
ART OR LIFE?
WE CANNOT AFFORD NEW OIL AND
GAS.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE EVERYTHING WE
KNOW AND MORE.
>> SO GROUPS LIKE THAT, THOSE
THUGS, THOSE MONITORS, THE
STALINIST MOBS DIDN'T APPEAR OUT
OF NOWHERE.
IT'S NOT ORGANIC.
THEY WERE WHIPPED INTO A FRENZY
BY JOHN KERRY, NANCY PELOSI AND
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
THAT WAS THEIR INSPIRATION.
THEY'RE DESTROYING THE THINGS
THAT HAVE MOST VALUABLE IN OUR
SOCIETY, OUR ART.
THE LEGACY OF OUR CIVILIZATION.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY HAVEN'T DONE?
THEY HAVEN'T SAID A SINGLE WORD
ABOUT AL GORE'S PERSONAL
GULFSTREAM OR JOHN KERRY ON PETE
BUTTIGIEG.
THEY'RE ATTACKING ART BUT NOT
SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ACTUALLY DESTROYING THE
CLIMATE?
WHO KNOW WHO ISN'T?
BLACK ROCK.
THE ESG SCORE THAT YOU HEAR
ABOUT.
>> John: YOU FLIGHTS ON PRIVATE
PLANES HAVE NO EFFECT ON AN ESG
SCORE.
REALLY?
BLACK ROCK DOESN'T SAY A WORD.
COULD IT BE THAT THE CLIMATE
MOVEMENT ISN'T REALLY ABOUT THE
CLIMATE OR ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT?
COULD IT BE THAT THE CLIMATE
MOVEMENT IS ABOUT CREATING A
PERMANENT CAST SYSTEM WHERE THE
PEOPLE AT THE TOP OF THE SOCIETY
CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT?
CAN VIOLATE WITH IMPUNITY THE
STANDARDS THAT THEY IMPOSE ON
OTHERS WHILE OPPRESSING THE
POPULATION SUPPOSEDLY RUNS THE
COUNTRY BUT ACTUALLY DOESN'T?
COULD IT BE?
IT'S POSSIBLE.
WE CALL PETE BUTTIGIEG'S OFFICE
TODAY AND ASKED HOW YOU CAN
JUSTIFY FLYING PRIVATE AS THE
EARTHS WARM AND THE SEAS RISE?
HOW ARE YOU NOT A CLIMATE
CRITICAL?
SPEAK SLOWLY SO WE CAN
UNDERSTAND.
THEY DIDN'T EXPLAIN.
THE REST OF US SHOULD IMPOSE
THIS AS A LITMUS TEST GOING
FORWARD.
NOBODY THAT SEEKS TO IMPOSE
CARBON RATIONING SHOULD EVER BE
ALLOWED TO STEP WITHIN 100 YARDS
OF A PRIVATE AIRCRAFT, PERIOD.
ANY ONE THAT CLAIMS TO BE
SERIOUS ABOUT FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE SHOULD DEMAND TOMORROW
MORNING A FEDERAL LAW AGAINST
PRIVATE AIR TRAVEL.
MAKE IT ILLEGAL.
FLY SPECIAL WITH EVERYONE ELSE
OR STAY HOME.
WHAT IS THE ARGUMENT AGAINST
THAT?
HERE'S WHAT YOU DO KNOW.